follow me there's something I need to
show you but you have to promise not to
run away there's a new wood you might
sign that rope around my waist and it's
just for mister hold on tight
wait what's happening this one's to come
meet the others Jake right on time
miss Peregrine's delighted to meet you
he's invisible of course where it's
known in common parlance as the Korea
it's a recessive gene carrying l3
families my peculiarities
because their abilities don't fit in the
outside world we live in places like
this to keep us safe we create a time
loop
the loop reserves the last 24 hours
reset the loop and you can stay here
forever I knew you were one of us when
you were born it's time for you to learn
what you can do I'm just more ordinary
no you're not
you were born to protect us from work
they call them hollows the centuries
they've hunted us for our powers I
assure you we are
you have the chance to do something to
change of everything obviously one thing
Jake that people golf to the mall I
promise there's a new world common my
dad said did everything had already been
discovered not everything Jake
how how did you yeah it's my
peculiarities if I show you the rest you
have to promise not to run away